Well from booty to Bucatini,
we're talking pasta in today's Food News.
(audience applauds)
Nom, nom, nom, nom.
Finally.
Okay.
I have been waiting for this moment.
The Good News Network reports
that there's a new pasta shape at the pasta party
and she's a flying off the shelves.
First, some backstory,
Dan Pashman, James Beard Award Winner and food podcaster,
set out to create the perfect pasta.
And he did a ton of research,
tried every shape,
and even went to a pasta lab.
By the way, that's where I wanna be buried.
Yeah, all of a sudden, I wanna be a scientist now.
No kidding.
Then he got with Brooklyn pasta makers, Sfoglini,
to invent the Casca, what the hell?
(audience laughs)
Cascatelli.
By the way,
everybody in Italy right now is like, "Shut up woman".
(audience laughs)
(Ross laughs)
Cascatelli.
So, we're here to try it.
It says that also, it's grooves and a toothiness.
Yeah, it's important, I think,
for pasta to sort of grab the sauce.
Like, "Hey, come on guys.
We're all gonna go in together."
And look at that, it totally does it.
It's so good.
Oh my God.
(audience applauds)
I'm in.
(Ross laughs)
I love it.
Mm-hm.
This is so delicious.
Ross, it's your story.
Yeah, we could talk about noodles all day long.
But congratulations, by the way,
on creating a new pasta.
It's about time.
(audience laughs)
You know, well.
Welcome to the family, Cascatelli.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
All right.
And finally,
nature lovers, looking for your next big adventure?
Look no further than the llama.
The Washington Post published a guide
on how to go hiking with a herd of llamas,
because we've all been waiting for that.
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
Here's how you do it, you don't ride the llama.
No, you hike alongside them.
And it's called Llama therapy,
because these guys are super peaceful
and they make the perfect pack animal.
They're llamas, all right?
And the point is, it's supposed to
chill you out a little bit.
But when you look at these pictures of these llamas,
I mean, I never thought,
it's never occurred to me,
"Oh, I'd love to go on a hike with a llama",
until I looked at these pictures.
And now all I can think about
is going on a hike with a llama.
(audience laughs)
And you can park them
and camp out and they just go with you for a while.
What's, what?
What's so funny?
Parking a llama.
I think that's what they're...
Oh. (laughs)
Well, I asked, do you tether them?
Do they just stay and, you know, watch out for you at night?
I wanted to know details
You park 'em and then walk away and go, boop-boop.
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
Anyway, we're gonna show on our website,
some opportunities,
if you're interested in getting with a llama,
and going on a nature walk.
You can go for a couple of hours or a couple of days.
Okay, I don't...
I mean, are you guys gonna do this?
Anyone gonna...
Nope.
(scattered audience whoops)
I think some people are interested.
May I ask why you raised your hands?
Well, we're actually taking our nine year old
to Yellowstone, in the next month or so
and she's really into alpacas and llamas.
(Ross gasps)
It's perfect.
It's perfect for us.
Are you a plant?
Right?
(audience laughs)
No, no.
You can't be serious?
You're going to Yellowstone with your kid
and she loves llamas?
Yes.
That is the truth.
Then Rossy, we were looking for someone
that this story speaks to.
This is not, this is gonna be a surprise to our producers,
but I would love to hook you up with a llama ride.
Ah!
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
She would love this.
She's gonna be so excited.
(bright theme music)